Speaker 1: OK, so Dr. Oz, a promoter of various
quack cures homeopathy, raspberry ketones,
green coffee bean extract, faith healing,
OK, energy healing and all these different
things.
He is running for Senate as a Republican in
Pennsylvania.
There's an opponent of his who's a great choice,
John Fetterman.
We've talked about that.
We've talked about his platform and his campaign
a little bit.
He is getting Dr. Oz's getting the hero's
welcome on Fox News.
Probably not coming as a surprise to most
of you, but softball interview after softball
interview over the last 24 hours on a whole
bunch of different shows.
Let's start with Dr. Oz's interview with Sean
Hannity last night.
Speaker 2: I can tell you in a minute what
my political philosophy is, but rather than
me, tell you mine, what is yours, right?
Well, I'll tell you one thing for sure any
government that's large enough to give you
everything is powerful enough to take it all
the way.
So I don't want that.
Speaker 1: That is that is a hell of a Republican
talking.
But he knows the talking points.
He has them prepared and this is the right
audience for them, that's for sure.
Speaker 2: Liberty and freedom.
And that, to me, means limited government.
We can do it better than folks very far away
from us who don't know our local problems.
The more we can be local, the more we can
trust the people in our communities, the better
off we are.
Speaker 1: It's funny because, you know, a
lot of the quack cures that he has promoted
on his show, his small government perspective
would be maybe that stuff shouldn't even be
regulated.
I don't like, yeah, maybe it should just be.
Well, if Dr. Oz promoted this, that's the
same as FDA approval.
I'm not saying he said that, but this thinking
of as little government as possible pushes
you in that direction.
Let's continue.
Speaker 2: I believe in energy independence.
That's a big deal here in Pennsylvania.
But we don't as a nation want to be begging
other countries like we're starting to do
to change what they're doing with energy because,
you know, we're in hock.
I believe in capitalism that which means lower
taxes and regulations so people can really
compete.
And I respect the Constitution.
I brilliantly written document that I think
should be honored on the bench and sometimes
isn't.
We have free market solutions that guys,
Speaker 1: he has this.
I mean, this is actually it's a minute, and
he hits like every Republican talking point
here
Speaker 2: and health care.
I'll tell you, this is my specialty area and
I spent my life studying this.
We can protect against preexisting conditions
and use free market solutions to health care
that makes it affordable, accessible for everybody.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine he's spent his
life studying health care and he has promoted
green coffee bean extract, raspberry ketones
and all that other stuff?
It's crazy, but he knows the talking points
he has been well-trained.
In this next clip on Fox and Friends, he warns
against mixing politics and medicine.
Can you imagine
Speaker 2: when you mix politics in medicine,
you get politics right?
What we witness not just with hydroxychloroquine,
but many other.
Motions that have been offered subsequently
is that there's a single perspective that's
allowed to get vaccinated.
Listen, I think one of the greatest accomplishments
of America is that we gave the world the many
vaccines through President Trump's Operation
Warp Speed.
I'm so happy that we were able to do that.
And I got vaccinated and I believe in vaccines.
I don't believe in mandates when you mix.
Speaker 1: It's so funny when he says, you
know, hydroxychloroquine became politicized.
Dude, you were on TV promoting it.
Absent actual medical evidence that it did
anything for COVID and subsequently its authorization
for emergency use was revoked by the FDA.
It's, you know, he has the Republican talking
points down.
He also has a Republican projection down perfectly.
Here's another one where he he's getting into.
We got to stop canceling and I mean, he you
got to hand it to him.
He came in prepared with all of the bullet
points that Republicans are currently using.
Speaker 2: I'm going to serve America.
His time of need, the best of my ability.
We need better solutions.
They're out there.
We ought to stop shaming and silencing and
bullying and canceling people with ideas that
are different than ours, especially when they're
good ideas, right?
That play out plenty in COVID.
And I got to say in medicine, when you cannot
say what you see, people die, so we ought
to be able to do at least that I'm going to
say,
Speaker 1: I mean, it's just it's it's all
backwards.
But this is exactly this is why his candidacy
has the potential to work absent any actual
policy, just stating these vague principles
that are abandoned when they don't coincide
with your beliefs.
We should be allowed to say things when there's
an idea about medicine.
Well, you talked about hydroxychloroquine
and it was debunked.
Well, but they shouldn't have canceled.
You can't cancel.
But it was a bad idea.
It it did not work.
Here he is, explaining why he's running.
Speaker 2: Here's my pledge, my promise to
everybody.
I want to be your public servant.
Yeah, and every choice I make will be serving
the citizens of Pennsylvania and the United
States.
And none of them will serve the special interests
in Washington, many of whom I've been to war
with for most of my career.
Let's reinvigorate America.
Speaker 1: I think he means at war with being
being to war with them.
It actually means something different, but
I think he means he's been against them.
Speaker 2: And let's see that divine spark
in each other because it's there.
Speaker 1: Dear God, it's weird.
He even mispronounced Pennsylvania as Pennsylvania,
like Trump does.
Like every aspect of this is very, very Trumpy.
Here's a clip that's kind of messed up.
The video is weird, but you can hear him say
a little bit about immigration.
Like, actually, this is the only thing I've
heard him say that approximates policy.
Speaker 2: Immigration is a big problem for
a couple of reasons.
For one.
We're subsidizing cartels, by
Speaker 1: the way, he's running in Pennsylvania.
Speaking of immigration,
Speaker 2: you're involved in human trafficking.
I mentioned you're bringing opiates across
the border, but lots of other issues as well.
I think President Trump was right.
People should wait on the Mexican side of
the border if they're coming across illegally.
Let's deal with all the issues there and not
put law enforcement in an impossible predicament
where they're forced now put people on this
country to chase them down.
When we know there are a couple.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You know, and of course, what's being ignored
when we don't even have to look, it's disgustingly
what's being ignored is they they also apply
that to people seeking asylum.
They say, well, they should seek asylum in
Mexico at an office like, well, a lot of times
people seeking asylum are in dire and dangerous
situations.
So that's why they're coming over and at the
border, saying I am seeking asylum.
It's a complicated issue.
I'm not pretending it's not.
But Dr. Oz presenting us the same simplistic
analysis that Donald Trump presented so welcomed
with open arms by right wing media.
We've got to be very careful.
This guy has a real shot not only at winning,
but it being the seat that decides whether
Democrats or Republicans control the Senate
starting in January of 2023.
We'll have more of this on our Instagram.
Find us on Instagram at David Pakman show.